vous savez qu'on parle au tout
aujourd'hui du retour des de conflits de
haute intensité et la question des
stocks de munition est majeure et pas
plus tard qu'avant-hier le secrétaire
général de l'OTAN déclarait que les pays
de l'OTAN qu'on se met aujourd'hui
davantage de munitions qu'ils ne
produisait donc avec un affaiblissement
des stocks et nos deux rapporteurs
Vincent Bru et Julien rancoul
ont mené près d'une vingtaine
d'auditions effectuer deux déplacements
pour comprendre cette évolution tant et
d'identifier les principaux leviers
d'une stratégie qui viserait à
recompléter nos stocks de munitions pour
nos armées mais également à améliorer
les flux de production industrielle donc
voilà je ne suis plus long messieurs je
vous souhaite la parole et je précise
quand même que lors de notre prochain
déplacement en Dordogne chez notre
collègue Jean-Pierre kubertin notamment
nous aurons l'occasion de visiter la
poudrerie de Bergerac pour ceux qui
veulent également approfondir le sujet
messieurs les rapporteurs vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le Président tout d'abord
Julien et moi nous voulons remercier
Aude Delvaux et Apolline Claude qui nous
ont accompagné pour la rédaction de de
ce rapport bien évidemment ainsi que
toutes les personnes qui ont accepté
d'être auditionnées ou qui nous ont reçu
sur site comme vous le venez de le
rappeler monsieur le président
en fait la déréation globale des stocks
français de munitions depuis la fin de
la guerre froide semble être devenu
insoutenable tant au regard du contexte
stratégique que des ambitions militaires
de la France
conséquence des dividendes de la paix
cette dégradation entraînée une
structuration de la filière
munitionnelle selon une logique de flux
et non pas une logique de stock
décider lors de la professionnalisation
des armées en 1996 amplifiée par la RGPP
la revue générale des politiques
publiques en 2007 puis par la crise
économique de 2008 la réduction
drastique des formats des armées et
l'adoption d'un modèle d'excellence
échantillonnaire on fait des munitions
il faut bien le reconnaître une variable
d'ajustement budgétaire
les attentats terroristes islamistes de
janvier puis de novembre 2015 et il a
mis un coup d'arrêt à cette politique de
réduction massive des budgets militaires
l'amorce de complètement des stocks
depuis 2016 permet de stopper
l'hémorragie la loi de programmation
militaire 2019-2025 inverse la
trajectoire à la baisse des stocks de
munitions
au début de la crise sanitaire un mars
avril 2020 l'épisode de pénurie de masse
respiratoire de protection bien
qu'interdire rappeler l'importance
cruciale de disposer de stocks
stratégiques pour faire face à l'imprévu
un constat apparu avec un corps plus
d'éclats depuis le retour du conflit de
intensité sur le continent européen un
changement de paradigme s'impose
désormais en matière de stock le retour
d'expérience du conflit ukrainien
illustre les multiples atouts
stratégiques que recel la constitution
de stocks de munitions
l'impératif de reconstitution des stocks
militaires et d'ailleurs un constat
partagé par de nombreux pays occidentaux
ce constat étant énoncé la
reconstitution des stocks de munitions
soulève des enjeux très différents selon
que l'on considère les munitions simples
ou des munitions complexes si la filière
munitionnaire française est relativement
homogène dans son organisation
structuré autour de grands maîtres
d'heures et de sous-traitants en
dialogue permanent avec les forces
armées les munitions balistiques sont
associées à une production de masse
tandis que les munitions propulsées que
sont des missiles et les torpilles sont
plus complexes à produire
ottoman technologique est propre à
l'engagement dit de haut de spectre ces
munitions se distinguent par leur portée
leur type de missions qui leur est
assigné et leur technicité générant bien
évidemment des coûts de développement
élevé et requérant bien souvent une
coopération internationale
sa missile ou centerpille un bâtiment ou
un aéronef perd de sa fonction
essentielle un Rafale n'est plus un
avion de chasse une frégate n'est plus
un bâtiment de guerre et un sous-marin
ne fait plus peser de menaces dans la
marine par exemple les munitions
complexes permettent d'avoir l'avantage
sur les adversaires de premier rang qui
souhaiteraient restreindre la liberté
d'action des forces navales françaises
dans les espaces aéromaritimes contestés
dans le cadre d'opération d'entrée en
premier ce type de munition permet
d'emporter le combat en mer pour ensuite
frapper dans la profondeur des terres à
l'aide à l'aide de chasseur
les missiles peuvent frapper depuis la
mer des objectifs stratégiques à terre
ou en mer ou encore intercepter d'autres
missiles pour défendre la force navale
contre les attaques adverses
la complexité des missiles et des
torpilles s'explique par plusieurs
facteurs notamment le rôle clé de la
Recherche Développement la pluralité des
niveaux de sous-traitance et le temps de
programmation puis de fabrication de ces
munitions pouvant s'étaler au total sur
une quinzaine d'années nous présentons
dans notre rapport une synthèse des
principales munitions complexes dans
leur mission de leur porter et leur
milieu ainsi que leurs atouts propres
nous tenons à préciser qu'en matière de
munitions les chiffres sont classifiés
et qu'il ne nous a pas été possible d'en
fournir de notre rapport nous le
regrettons quelque peu mais nous
comprenons l'impératif de ne pas
divulguer ce type d'éléments auprès de
nos compétiteurs nous précisons aussi
que pour la même raison nous avons
totalement exclu le nucléaire de notre
champ d'investigation
la conception la production le cycle de
vie des munitions s'étale dans un temps
long qui contraste avec la rapidité de
la frappe la vitesse supersonique de
domicile et la trission trop tôt venue
bien qu'après des années de pénurie le
contexte actuel suscite un sentiment
d'urgence à reconstituer nos stocks ce
contraste entre temps de production et
tant d'emploi un site à prendre le temps
de la réflexion nécessaire à
l'anticipation d'une stratégie à long
terme qui aurait un impact sur la
filière des munitions dans les décennies
à venir
qui nous paraît capital et sur lequel
nous tenons tous deux à insister
la reconstitution des stocks suppose
donc la prise en compte des armées pour
par les armées des enjeux à la fois
stratégiques
capacités
d'abord qui sont corrélés aux ambitions
stratégiques de la France la
reconstitution des stocks doit se faire
en harmonie avec des hypothèses
d'engagement envisagées et également
l'accroissement des besoins dus à
l'intensification de la préparation
opérationnelle provenir si vous voulez
la reconstitution des stocks doit aussi
tenir compte d'une certaine cohérence
capacitaire entre nos trois armées et
également entre les couples vecteurs et
munitions ou encore entre le haut et le
bas du spectre équilibre que nous
appellerons panachage
enfin les jeux logistiques tenant à la
sécurité et à la périssabilité des
munitions conditionnent cette montée en
puissance
c'est pourquoi nous proposons d'adapter
le recomplètement des stocks de
munitions à des hypothèses d'engagement
renouvelées de favoriser l'utilisation
de munitions réelles dans le cadre de la
préparation opérationnel quittant à
s'intensifier et de favoriser le
panachage de munitions entre masse et
technologies
qui nous paraît capital sur lequel nous
tenons tous les deux insistés la
complémentarité entre munitions de
saturation et de munitions intelligente
mais en évidence la nécessité d'assurer
un panacha HP pertinent que ce soit pour
l'artillerie la défense antichard ou la
défense anti-aérienne il faut
suffisamment de munitions simples pour
traiter 90% des objectifs et une large
gamme de munitions complexe destinée à
traiter 10% des cibles trop persistantes
pour des munitions simples
Tussion des stocks et le stockage des
munitions sont aussi soumis à de
multiples contraintes logistiques de
fait la sécurité pyrotechnique repose
sur un cadre normatif très strict les
munitions étant des objets par nature
dangereux l'impératif de sécurité
commande non seulement des normes mais
aussi toute une culture pyrotechnique
que nous avons pu constater lors de
notre déplacement sur le site du simu
service interne de munitions à Savigny
en septaine près de la base aérienne
d'avorde près de Bourges cet impératif
de sécurité impose aussi des contraintes
logistiques majeures pour le stockage de
nos munitions en particulier des igloos
que nous avons pu visiter des magasins
enterrés ou semi-enterrés des poudrières
des cavernes
nous estimons que les normes applicables
sont essentielles en ce qu'elle offre
des garanties de sécurité et de
protection vis-à-vis des personnels et
qui augmentent de ce fait
l'acceptabilité de munitions cependant
bon nombre de normes applicables
militaires répandent aux exigences
résultant d'accidents survenus dans le
secteur industriel civil nous estimons
pour notre part que des exigences
normatives appliquaient nos armées
devraient être mieux proportionnés aux
enjeux de sécurité réelle en
privilégiant une approche de gestion de
risques la simplification des normes est
d'ailleurs encore plus nécessaire dans
la perspective d'un conflit de haute
intensité
de même la périssabilité des munitions
doit par définition être anticipé raison
pour laquelle les armées échelonnent
leur commande afin de ne pas devoir
renouveler tous les stocks en même temps
il s'agit aussi d'optimiser le maintien
en conditions opérationnelles des
missiles en améliore la disponibilité
des parcs sur ce point nous préconisons
lorsque c'est possible bien sûr ce n'est
pas toujours le cas de réinternaliser le
maintien en conditions opérationnelles
des missiles aujourd'hui assurer par les
industriels MDPH en particulier nous
proposons aussi de prévoir
systématiquement dans les contrats de
maintenance des clauses stipulant un
seuil minimal de disponibilité des mines
t-il enfin nous jugeons opportun que
lorsque c'est possible les industriels
puissent assurer le cas échéant le
maintien en conditions opérationnelles
des munitions au plus près des
opérations sur des bases projetées ce
qui éviterait au missiles de faire des
allers-retours entre les bases et les
sites de production en particulier à
Bourges
si la politique de remonter des stocks
relèvent des armées l'intensification
des flux de production relèvent des
industriels et c'est un complément
indispensable à la reconstitution de nos
stocks le besoin de masse et d'épaisseur
qui ressort des retours d'expérience de
champ de bataille mettant lumière
l'indispensable continuité entre stock
et flux devant permettre aux forces sous
faible préavis de prendre l'ascendant
opérationnel sur l'adversaire les stocks
assument surtout un rôle tampon
permettant à la production industrielle
de prendre rapidement le relais au
soutien des forces armées
est donc d'abat d'adapter la base
industrielle et technologique de défense
française la BITD aux exigences d'un
champ de bataille durcie c'est l'objet
de l'économie de guerre dans cette
perspective garantir la soutenabilité
économique des entreprises
mutitionnelles munitionnaires pardon
mise à l'épreuve par les dividendes de
la paix en assurant la visibilité et la
régularité des commandes est un
préalable les acteurs industriels
auditionnés d'ailleurs ont une animement
souligné le manque de visibilité de la
commande publique qu'il est prible de
toute faculté d'anticipation des besoins
des forces dans les stocks sont
évidemment classifiés et donc
d'anticipation des quantités à produire
il en résulte une utilisation sous
optimale de l'outil de production
interne et de la chaîne que les
industriels équilibrent le plus souvent
est fort heureusement grâce à l'export
70% pour Nexter 75%. c'est pourquoi nous
préconisons d'affermir la visibilité
pour les entreprises ainsi que la
régularité des commandes étatiques
nous en venons à présent à un enjeu
particulièrement important à nos yeux
celui de la filière de petit calibre
la filière munitionnaire française est
quasi intégralement souveraine vous le
savez chers collègues la filière
française du petit calibre a été
abandonné en 1999
les causes de l'absence d'industrie mini
chaudière de petits calibres en France
étaient à l'époque principalement
économique le marché mondial du petit
calibre est en unanimement considéré
jusqu'à il y a encore peu comme abondant
et fortement concurrentiel
j'estime pour ma part que cette analyse
qui émane du ministère des armées et en
particulier de la DGA et dater au vu de
l'inflation du prix des munitions de
petits calibres et du contexte
stratégique international la France
n'est plus dans la même situation depuis
2020 le ministère de l'Intérieur que
nous avons auditionné nous a fait part
de ces difficultés à s'approvisionner en
munition de petit calibre au profit des
forces de l'ordre au début du conflit
ukrainien
alors que le ministère de l'Intérieur ne
disposait que de deux mois de stock il
lui a été impossible de se fournir sur
le marché intérieur national y compris
européen la bonne santé économique de la
filière américaine notamment du petit
calibre a pour corollaire un
rachatissement des prix subis par les
clients c'est pourquoi il nous semble
que les conditions économiques de
relocalisation de la filière ont évolué
depuis la dernière étude menée par le
ministère des armées nous jugeons tous
deux que le projet de relocalisation
porté par le ministère de l'Intérieur et
particulièrement intéressant il s'agit
de créer une filière de 9 pour les pour
des donc pour des munitions de 9 mm sur
le territoire national à partir de la
réhabilitation d'anciennes usines
initiales initialement destiné aux
forces de sécurité intérieure cette
filière pourrait par la suite ou en cas
d'urgence nécessité couper sa production
de 9 mm avec du sel du 556 par exemple
plus spécifiquement destiné aux forces
armées
si je soutiens l'idée d'ensemble je
mettrai pour ma part quelques réserves à
ce projet de relocalisation
naturellement si elle doit être
effectuée la rentabilité du projet doit
être garantie par des exportations et la
production ne doit pas créer un déficit
que l'État devrait combler à défaut de
filière nationale une filière de petits
calibres en coopération avec un voisin
européen tel que notre partenaire belge
qui a fait des propositions dans ce sens
pourrait être envisagées en tout état de
cause nous tenons tous les deux à ce que
cette reconnaissance soit sérieusement
étudiée à l'échelon interministérielle
et nous répondrons si vous le souhaitez
à des questions sur ce point
nous en venons maintenant aux différents
leviers à actionner dans le cas d'une
économie de guerre pour accélérer la
montée en cadence de la production de
munitions
le premier levier actionné consiste
selon nous à simplifier les exigences et
les normes tout comme les forces les
industriels sont soumis à un corpus
réglementaire très dense régissant les
activités attenantes aux munitions or
les normes en vigueur sont très élevées
par rapport à celle qui s'appliquent sur
le marché international conduisant un
renchérissement des coûts et à une
augmentation des délais de production
pour un bénéfice opérationnel souvent
discutable
le degré de préconisations de précaution
pardon imposer doit d'ailleurs être
relativisé au regard des réalités du
terrain nous essayons tous les deux
qu'il est nécessaire d'adapter les
normes applicables aux industriels aux
conditions d'emploi des munitions
l'enjeu est de trouver un juste
équilibre entre sécurité et pragmatisme
ce qui suppose de redéfinir la culture
du risque et d'adopter une approche de
gestion du risque
toujours s'agissant de la simplification
des normes il faut revenir quelques
instants sur la réglementation
européenne riches qui concerne
l'enregistrement l'évaluation
l'autorisation des substances chimiques
ce règlement européen qui a été qui est
entré en vigueur au 1er juin 2007 est un
sujet de préoccupation majeure pour les
acteurs de la filière munitionnaire en
ce qui l'entraîne l'obsolescent de
certains produits pour lesquels aucune
alternative n'a été trouvée à ce jour le
processus d'autorisation prévu par le
règlement a pour effet d'allonger les
délais d'obtention d'autorisation
d'utilisation de ces produits auprès de
la Commission européenne ce processus
menace directement l'usage du plomb et
des selles de plomb qui sont au
fondement de toutes chaînes
pyrotechnique c'est pourquoi nous
considérons qu'il conviendrait
impérativement de prévoir des exemptions
à la réglementation REACH au préfet de
la filière munitionnaire de défense
formulons une proposition dans ce sens
et peut-être des questions pour être
posées sur ce sujet
nous préconisons aussi toujours dans une
optique d'économie de guerre de
faciliter l'approvisionnement en
matériaux et en sous-ensemble critique
en relocalisant ce qui peut l'être et en
constituant des prestoques de fait les
dépendances au matériaux critiques
constituent un véritable facteur de
fragilité notamment pour les
sous-traitants les difficultés
d'approvisionnement actuellement vécues
en temps de crise internationale ne
ferait que sa croître dans l'hypothèse
d'un engagement majeur de notre pays
contre un compétiteur stratégique
disposez donc de prestoque de composants
stratégiques et de sous-ensemble
constitutifs souvent simples mais long à
produire permet de réduire le cycle de
production
nous proposons aussi de relocaliser les
filières les plus stratégiques pour
l'industrie munitionnaire notamment dans
le domaine des poudres je rappelle que
la phrase ne dispose pas d'autonomie
stratégique en ce domaine et qu'elle
doit notamment se fournir en Allemagne
sur ce segment or l'Allemagne privilégie
JIRA sans doute ses propres forces en
cas d'engagement majeur nous jugeons
aussi nécessaire de remettre en cause
les dépendances les plus structurées en
particulier dans le domaine des
semi-conducteurs rappelons que l'Union
européenne produisait 40% des semis
conducteurs sur le marché mondial en
1990 contre moins de 10% désormais
un autre axe de réflexion majeur et
celui des ressources humaines
c'est une évidence les ouvriers de la
pyrotechnique constitue une ressource
rare outre leur compétences techniques
très pointues ils doivent présenter un
profil psychologique jugé apte à être au
contact de manière de matière explosive
si la filière des munitions ne rencontre
pas de difficultés de ressources
humaines particulièrement handicapantes
à ce stade il convient de prendre en
compte l'enjeu des ressources humaines
et la forme à la formation pardon des
personnels pyrotechniques
dans la perspective de la perspective
pardon d'une économie de guerre le
redimensionnement de l'outil industriel
nécessite nécessiterait la mobilisation
rapide de personnel immédiate
immédiatement opérationnel à cette fin
une première piste pour écosysté à
adapter à adapter les règles liées au
temps du travail l'idée de constituer
une réserve industrielle constituée
notamment de jeunes salariés de
l'industrie munitionnaire serait
également à envisager
c'est d'ailleurs le sens de l'une des
propositions got nous faisons toujours
dans la même optique et en complément de
cette réserve de cette réserve
industrielle je suggère l'idée de
constituer une réserve opérationnelle
spécifiquement dédiée à la filière
industrielle et je crois que mon
collègue COA porteur ne serait pas
opposé si vous voulez on pourrait
revenir si une question est posée par la
suite enfin le redéploiement des
personnels dédiés aux Chênes civiles
vers des chaînes militaires au sein
d'entreprises dual qui ont une activité
civile et militaire est tout à fait
possible à certaines conditions lorsque
naturellement les compétences sont
requises
dernier point abordé dans notre rapport
dans l'optique d'une économie de guerre
nous envisageons la préparation de
l'avenir la maturation de cette
préparation requiert elle aussi de
l'anticipation l'histoire de la guerre
illustre un effet à quel point
l'innovation technique et technologique
conditionne à la souveraineté et
l'autonomie stratégique d'un état tant
pour préserver sa crédibilité sur la
scène internationale dans une logique
dissuasive que pour assurer sa
supériorité sur le champ de bataille les
missiles hypersoniques la technologie
quantique les armes à énergie dirigées
sont d’autres autant d'axes d'efforts
devant garantir la crédibilité de nos
forces la maîtrise des capacités de haut
du spectre doit permettre d'assurer
demain les opérations d'entrée en
premier
cette nécessité de préparer l'avenir ne
cesse de se renforcer à l'allure de
l'évolution des menaces dans un
environnement stratégique
caractéristique par le caractériser par
le retour des états puissances le
détournement de technologie
issue du monde civil et l'accélération
constante du rythme de l'innovation
facilité par le développement d'une
numérique encore une fois cette
nécessité d'innover ne doit pas occulter
l'importance cruciale du panachage entre
masse et technologies évoquée en amont
il convient donc d'accompagner les
évolutions et technologiques
prioritaires parmi elles nous avons
notamment identifié l'allongement des
portées l'amélioration de la précision
et la diversification des effets des
munitions actuelles
la sophistication croissante des
munitions va dans le sens de l'entrée en
service progressive des munitions de
plus en plus précises aux effets de plus
en plus modulables
l'objectif clé est bien d'optimiser les
performances des munitions des munitions
selon les axes que nous venons de citer
ainsi par exemple l'obus de précision
155 mm katana développé par Nexter vise
un cercle d'erreur probable de niveau de
niveau décamétrique 50% d'écoute ont
beurrés à moins de 10% de 10 mètres
pardon de leur cible cette munition
d'artillerie intelligente offre
l'avantage ne pas requérir d'infras
d'infrastructures ou de changements
lourds des forces
face à l'augmentation globale de
l'intelligence des missiles les systèmes
de contre-mesure doivent également être
perfectionnés pour continuer de les
contrer les évolutions privilégiées les
des systèmes de protection multicouche
alliant plusieurs types de masquage
l'orage
un exemple particulièrement intéressant
d'innovation à accompagner celui des
munitions téléopérée apparues à
l'automne 2020 dans le conflit du haut
Karaba entre l'Azerbaïdjan et l'Arménie
puis lors du conflit
ukrainien ces munitions ce sont
désormais imposées sur le champ de
bataille il s'agit de munitions de masse
destinée à frapper l'ennemi tant sur le
plan matériel que sur le plan
psychologique
ces munitions présentent l'avantage
d'être généralement très peu cher et là
on estime que pour 1 euro dépensé dans
une munition téléopérée les dégâts sur
le matériel ennemi atteint entre 5 et 15
euros
en outre la destruction d'une munition
telle opérée emporte moins de
conséquences que celle d'un avion
utilisez en masse ces munitions
permettent de saturer facilement
l'espace aérien adverse et de natural et
de neutraliser ses défenses
anti-aériennes en outre les agréments
apportés permettent de plus en plus
d'allonger la portée des munitions
téléopérée pour frapper dans la
profondeur enfin la projection de ces
munitions exerce une forte pression
psychologique distillant la peur sur le
champ de bataille
en matière de munition téléopérée il
faut constater que la France accuse un
retard extrêmement important et qu'elle
doit rattraper de toute urgence d'où
l'importance de soutenir l'effort
annoncé par le ministre des Armées
récemment Sébastien Lecornu dans le
cadre de la future loi de programmation
militaire visant à doter les forces
françaises selon lui de plusieurs
milliers de munitions téléopérée à
l'horizon 2030 ce sont les appels à
projets larinés et colibri dont nous
parlons actuellement il nous semble
essentiel de favoriser une fabrication
française limitant au maximum les
composants importés de l'étranger mais
également de se doter de plusieurs
milliers de munitions contenus de leur
forte attrition
sur le plan défensif en effet les
margences de ces nouvelles munitions sur
le champ de bataille imposent de
renforcer et d'adapter aussi nos moyens
de défense anti-aériennes en un mot nous
proposons de doter les forces de l'eau
de munitions téléopérée capable de faire
face à la tricion propre à la haute
intensité et de répondre aux besoins du
terrain
dernière proposition de notre rapport et
non des moindres nous jugeons essentiel
de renforcer le soutien à la recherche
développement nous estimons en effet que
la remontée en puissance des stocks de
munitions ne doit pas se faire au
détriment des budgets de recherche
développement alors que la filière
souffre déjà d'un sou des
investissements critique en matière
d'innovation il s'agit en effet de
conserver notre supériorité
opérationnelle face à des compétiteurs
stratégiques qui investissent
massivement dans la préparation de
l'avenir l'ensemble des acteurs que nous
avons auditionné a souligner
l'importance capitale d'investir dans
les études en amont afin que nos armées
restent en mesure de faire face aux
menaces actuelles et futures
pour conclure je tiens également à
m'associer à mon collègue pour remercier
Aude Delvaux et Apolline pour le travail
exemplaire qu'elles ont fourni durant
ces deux mois je tiens également à
remercier Vincent Bru je trouve qu'on a
fait un travail ça a été vraiment un
plaisir de travailler donc à tes côtés
et je pense que on a travaillé en bon
intelligence et qu'on est d'accord on
est d'accord je passe sur l'intégralité
du constat et sur la sur la plupart des
propositions aussi apportées dans ce
rapport donc je remercie l'ensemble des
acteurs également des auditionnés durant
cette mission voilà chers collègues nous
vous remercions de votre attention et
nous sommes prêts à répondre à vos
interrogations je vous remercie merci à
tous les deux pour votre travail sur ce
sujet-ci si important alors nous avons
une trentaine de minutes et une dizaine
de questions donc si possible si vous
pouvez vous limitez dans la durée de vos
questions pour laisser un peu de temps
en rapporteur pour répondre ce serait
super pour le groupe Renaissance la
parole est à Benoît Borda
chers collègues rapporteur monsieur le
Président je vous remercie au nom du
groupe renaissance pour vos propos
liminaires très intéressants et très
complet je souhaiterais faire un focus
sur la question des matières premières
nécessaires à notre industrie française
de défense pour la production de nos
munitions avec les délais
d'approvisionnement pour certains
composants il faut 2 à 3 ans pour
fabriquer une munition dite complexe
comme un missile ainsi pouvez-vous nous
orienter sur les axes à approfondir pour
sécuriser nos approvisionnements en
matière critique je souhaite également
chers collègues évoquer la question des
normes appliqués aux activités
militaires et en particulier à la
gestion des dépôts de munitions je
souhaiterais notamment savoir si vous
estimez que nos normes sont trop
strictes et si oui préconisez-vous un
changement d'après sur la gestion des
stocks de matières premières pour
pouvoir répondre plus rapidement aux
besoins exprimés telles sont les deux
points d'attention je vous les soulever
et je voulais aussi souligner et saluer
la décision du Président de la
République très récemment d'avoir
débloqué 24 millions d'euros en urgence
pour approvisionner et acheter des armes
antichard je vous remercie merci pour le
groupe rassemblement national la parole
est à José Gonzalez
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le corbeau coraporteur tout d'abord
permettez-moi au nom du groupe du
Rassemblement national de vous féliciter
de vous remercier pour le travail que
vous avez effectué ensemble dans cette
mission il est évident que les travaux
que vous menez vont servir à la
réflexion de des membres de cette
commission à l'aube de la future loi de
programmation militaire et c'est ce
pourquoi il nous tarde de lire votre
rapport
ceci étant dit sur ce nouveau point
j'aimerais rappeler l'attachement du
groupe du Rassemblement national à
l'indépendance et à la souveraineté de
la France laquelle doit je le pense
privilégier une logique de stock et non
de flux tendus tels que cela a prévu ces
dernières années si l'on veut pouvoir
faire face au premier choc d'un conflit
de haute intensité dans cette lignée il
semble primordial d'augmenter le volume
de nos stocks de munitions si on veut
garantir notre autonomie stratégique or
pour y parvenir il convient de
s'interroger sur la nécessité sur la
nécessaire relocalisation d'une filière
de munition notamment de polycati de
petits calibres je parle le petit
calibre le 5 56 le 762 9 mm ou 12,7
effectivement nous avons sacrifié un
fleuron de l'industrie française manurin
il y a quelques temps et nous sommes
maintenant dépendants de l'Allemagne du
Royaume-Uni des États-Unis des émirats
et du Brésil rappelant que pendant
l'invasion de la Crimée par la Russie la
livraison des kalimes 9 mm qui servent
surtout aux armes de pointe de la
gendarmerie et de la police a eu un
retard de neuf mois alors cette question
est plus que jamais actuelle non
seulement du fait du retour de la guerre
sur notre continent avec des risques
certains mais aussi car la pandémie du
covid 19 a mis un exergue la dépendance
de la France aux États étrangers avec
l'exemple ahurissant de masque de
protection dont la pénurie passée dans
nos alertés quant à nos stocks de
munitions et certes on l'assoulinet tout
à l'heure en période de guerre il y a
des alliés mais surtout des intérêt
internationaux et on n'est jamais si
bien servi que par soi-même à cet égard
messieurs les corps rapporteurs
plusieurs questions me viennent
corollaire les unes des autres
premièrement qu'est-il réellement de
possible de relocaliser en France
deuxièmement quelle solution doit-on
envisager pour y parvenir et enfin quels
sont les éléments de notre rapport que
votre rapport vous a permis de mettre en
lumière pour atteindre cet objectif
d'indépendance et de souveraineté merci
à tous les deux merci pour le groupe les
républicain la parole est à Jean-Louis
thierryau
[Musique]
pour cette présentation de qualité vous
avez évoqué un sujet à la fois capital
en ce qui concerne l'économie de guerre
et sur lequel nous avions déjà attiré
l'attention dans d'autres missions que
nous avions fait sur l'abbéité des ou
sur la haute intensité c'est la
nécessité pour nos industriels d'avoir
une vision à long terme en ce qui
concerne leur carnet de commandes
en même temps le ministre des Armées
ainsi sur la nécessité pour nos
industriels de prendre une part de
risques ce qu'on peut entendre mais un
industriel ne peut prendre que des
risques calculés qui lui permettent
d'amortir les chaînes de production ou
les outils industriels qu'ils
développent donc ma question concerne
les outils juridiques qui pourraient
être développés il y a évidemment les
commandes fermes ça c'est tout simple
mais avez-vous travaillé sur des outils
qui pourrait être des lettres de confort
des lettres d'intention ou des outils ou
une commande minimum est garantie
seulement si des débouchés à l'export ne
sont pas trouvés ce qui permettrait à la
fois de lisser les carnets de commandes
et de permettre aux industriels d'aller
plus loin dans dans les investissements
qu'il doit faire deuxième question mais
qui rejoint la première vous avez évoqué
un sujet majeur qui est celui des
pré-stocks qui sont nécessaires quel
financement voyez-vous pour ces
prestoques nous avions travaillé
là-dessus aussi dans notre mission sur
la haute intensité cela doit-il être un
financement étatique cela devrait-il
être une mutualisation des stocks avec
des flux glissants c'est-à-dire que des
industriels investissent dans un stock
et le flux sortant est remplacé par du
flux rentrant enfin bref quel est votre
vision sur ce sujet je vous remercie
merci pour le groupe démocrate la parole
est à
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur les rapporteurs chers collègues
le groupe démocrate vous remercie pour
vos travaux très éclairants à tous les
deux ainsi qu'avec les personnes qui
vous ont effectivement accompagné la
guerre en Ukraine a révélé que la
question des stocks des munitions et
particulièrement particulièrement
importantes et sensible alors que la
France a longtemps sous-investit dans
les armées et qu'elle se doit désormais
de se préparer à l'intervenir dans un
conflit de haute intensité il est
important que nous reconstituions nos
stocks de munitions comme vous l'avez
évoqué cela impose d'avoir une mobilité
dès qu'il soit en capacité de répondre
aux besoins des armées françaises et la
LPM que nous allons bientôt étudier pour
insister sur la nécessité pour l'état de
donner des gages aux industriels et des
perspectives pour les commandes nous
devons aussi penser à nos alliés
européens avec qui nous collaborons pour
produire des armes et des munitions et
pour en fournir à l'Ukraine et le
secrétaire général de l'OTAN à alerter
les états de l'Alliance sur le fait que
le rythme actuel de consommation des
munitions par les forces ukrainiennes et
bien plus élevées que le rythme de
production des industries de défense
européenne dans le contexte d'une guerre
de haute intensité l'inconvalitat par le
biais des industriels d'accroître
significativement sac à dense de
production et de munitions les matières
premières en cas d'entités sont
essentielles mais les ressources
humaines doivent soutenir l'effort
comment les industriels peuvent-ils
garantir cette hausse de ressources
humaines dans ce contexte comme vous
l'avez montré il y a avant tout un enjeu
stratégique à développer la filière
munitionnaire française pardon dans le
rapport de la commission de la défense
sur la filière munition datant de 2015
les corps rapporteurs alertaient déjà
sur le défi que représenterait l'entrée
en vigueur de la réglementation
européenne riches qui représenterait un
coup significatif affectant
particulièrement l'industrie
munitionnelle huit ans plus tard la
question de toujours d'actualité dans
quelle mesure les enjeux de cette
réglementation
menacent-ils la filière munitionnaire
française et par conséquent l'autonomie
stratégique de nos forces et quelles
solutions peuvent être privilégiées pour
y remédier je vous remercie merci pour
le groupe socialiste la parole est à
Mélanie Thomas merci monsieur le
Président merci pour votre travail chers
collègues rapporteur
il faut écho à des travaux précédents
concernant les politiques
d'approvisionnement de nos armées qui
avaient été menées
dans dans les législatures précédentes
notamment par le président Chassaigne
alors évidemment il s'agit d'une
question clé de la capacité de nos
armées sans doute trop négligées
antérieurement à l'agression de la
Russie en 2022
aujourd'hui l'enjeu de nos réflexions et
de ne pas dupliquer les besoins de
l'Ukraine pour la France puissance dotée
ou l'Union européenne de la même manière
que pour la défense solaire notre
liberté d'action se mesurera à l'aune
d'assurer la dissuasion par nos forces
conventionnelles de défense et d'autre
part notre capacité à soutenir nos
alliés rapidement et forcément et
fortement alors quelle analyse
faites-vous de l'importance des stocks
nominaux d'armement et leur partage à
l'échelle européenne ou coexistent des
systèmes d'armes différents et enfin
comment considérer la plasticité de nos
industries européennes pour assurer des
montées en charge rapide subie ou
souhaité et comment la mettre en oeuvre
en incitant une trajectoire d'autonomie
européenne si celle-ci n'est pas
utopique et permettez-moi aussi aussi de
vous demander une réaction parce que
nous avons eu l'occasion
d'entendre hier les propos du secrétaire
général de l'Alliance atlantique
monsieur James toltonberg qui hier a
fait l'aveu que l'Europe est à court de
munitions alors je voulais avoir
vos réactions à ce sujet je vous
remercie merci pour le groupe horizon la
parole est à Jean-Charles arseneur merci
monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
cher rapporteur pour ce travail fourni
et méticuleux j'aurais deux questions
l'une sur les normes l'autre sur le
petit calibre sur les normes vous avez
évoqué l'impératif de sécurité qui
s'impose
nos armées ont eu une approche une
politique
parfois
caractérise de muratisation vous savez
pour les munitions à risque atténués qui
vivent évidemment à résister et pour ces
munitions une agressions externes je
pense par exemple à des munitions
embarquées sur un porte-avion ou bien
sûr il faut pouvoir résister à
différents rayonnement
électromagnétiques et des sources de
radioactivité etc est-ce que vous avez
dans le cadre de votre travaux
poursuivi la réflexion sur la question
des normes des spécifications peut-être
des sources spécifications et de celles
qui pourraient ou pas procéder ou en
tout cas nécessité des ajustements je
vous remercie pour vos réflexions à ce
sujet deuxième point la filière petit
calibre comme vous je pense que le
contexte a évolué je pense que votre
point d'entrée par les forces de
sécurité intérieure
est intéressant parce qu'en effet ce
sont principalement les forces de police
de gendarmerie qui ont connu un stress
eux ils vous l'avez dit au moment du
début de la guerre en Ukraine et je
voudrais aller un petit peu plus loin
avec vous sur cette question c'est vrai
que différentes approches sont possibles
en effet il faut la filière soit
rentable vous avez cité
je pense évidemment à fenerstal bon
est-ce que vous avez travaillé avec des
industriels français avec des sites
français et je parle d'une manière
intéressée à mon territoire puisque
depuis du Finistère il y a un site bien
connu à Pont de Buis
qui chez la circonscription de la
collecte demain oui on en lui cette
hommage voilà et donc est-ce que vous
avez pu échanger que c'est industriel et
comment voit-il la relance de ces
filières de petit calibre singulièrement
pour ne force de sécurité intérieure je
vous remercie merci chers collègues
alors il nous reste 20 minutes et nous
avons encore 5 questions complémentaires
je propose aux orateurs de si possible
de se limiter à une minute la parole est
à Michel Martinez
merci monsieur le Président mais si les
corps-à-porteurs mes chers collègues et
nous avons entendu la semaine dernière
madame liso et Madame pique nous
présenter leur mission d'information sur
la préparation opérationnelle nous avons
tous été d'accord sur le fait que des
efforts devaient être mis en place afin
d'intensifier cette dernière notamment
dans le cadre des conflits de haute
intensité et donc à fortiori si le
nombre d'entraînements augmente le
nombre de munitions nécessaires au
déroulement de ceci augmente aussi de
même afin que les entraînements
apparaissent le plus proche de la
réalité du terrain utilisez des
munitions réelles lors de ceci apparaît
comme une solution et cela permettait de
mettre en place un roulement perpétuel
dans les bases de stockage et d'éviter
les pertes de munition dues à leur
péremption
la question est donc la suivante comment
la croisement des besoins à
l'entraînement s'intègrent-ils dans la
recomplétion des stocks de munitions je
vous remercie merci la parole est à
Jean-Pierre cuirt à fond
c'est pas une question en fait c'est une
remarque nous avions réalisé en 2020
avec le président Chassaigne un travail
qui était la politique
d'approvisionnement des équipements dont
les munitions et nous nous étions rendus
justement à Pont de Buis chez Nobel
sport il faut peut-être pas le citer et
qui était à l'époque tout à fait
favorable à la fabrication de nous ça
comporter les petits équipements mais
bien entendu les munitions étaient
comprises alors je vous invite mes chers
collègues à relire ce travail peut-être
que vous avez déjà fait merci
merci la parole est amicale taverne
qui pourrait être justement destiné aux
forces de sécurité intérieure et aux
armées merci merci la parole est à
Yannick Beko merci monsieur le Président
moi je souhaiterais aller au-delà des
stocks de munitions proprement dit pour
orienter ma question vers les stocks
militaires et plus particulièrement ceux
de l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace
la logique d'économie de guerre dans
laquelle nous avons récemment basculé
impose effectivement de réapprovisionner
les stocks de munitions et si le PDF de
1023 affecte 2 milliards d'euros
d'autorisation d'engagement pour le
stock de munitions et notamment des
missiles RR Mika qu'en est-il par
exemple des stocks militaires
par exemple ces avions de combat sans
lesquels l'utilité des missiles
resteraient vaines et le conflit
ukrainien nous a démontré que même des
engins anciens mais maintenu
opérationnel pouvait s'avérer décisif
lors des combats donc plus généralement
est-ce que vous avez effectué des une
réflexion est-ce que vous avez une
réflexion sur le passage de nos modèles
de production et d'équipement des forces
d'une logique de flux tendue plus adapté
à des interventions ponctuelles et
choisis sur la scène internationale à
une logique de stock pour pouvoir
répondre à des crises et à l'hypothèse
d'un engagement majeur est-ce que vous
avez des orientations sur sur ce ce
point plus précisément je vous remercie
merci et enfin la parole est à Frédéric
bocaletti ce président mais sur les
rapporteurs à l'occasion de votre
présentation vous avez insisté sur la
nécessité d'entretenir un stock de
munitions cohérent et suffisant celui-ci
devant permettre aux armées d'organiser
une réponse rapide à toutes les crises
auxquelles elle serait susceptibles
d'être confrontées cela doit mon sens
passer par la relocalisation des
productions de munitions afin de
garantir la souveraineté de la nation
de plus le soutien l'investissement de
ces filières de production de munitions
en France permettrait également de
reconstruire une filière nationale
d'excellence et retombées économiques
pour la nation seraient non négligeable
je pense notamment à l'emploi et la
redynamisation économique des
territoires devenus des déserts
industriels dès lors pouvez-vous me dire
nous en dire un petit peu plus sur la
possible création d'un programme de
pilotage de la direct avec la Direction
générale de l'armement visant à soutenir
les entreprises de la défense je vous
remercie merci messieurs les rapporteurs
nous avons une quinzaine de minutes
devant nous je vous laisse vous
organiser pour savoir qui commence
bien nous allons répondre d'abord à
Monsieur Benoît bordade groupe du groupe
naissances merci pour votre pour votre
question
approvisionnement en matière critique je
crois qu'on a un petit peu parlé dans
dans la présentation les semis
conducteurs qui sont essentiellement
situés en Asie et notamment en Taïwan et
qui pourrait poser problème si dans le
cadre de notre défense des nos
territoires d'outre-mer il y avait des
des
conflits d'intensité dans dans cette
dans cette zone là on a dit je crois
tout à l'heure que nous souhaitons un
développement européen
mon collègue a rappelé que en 1990 44%
de la production de semi-conducteur
était européenne et elle est tombée à 9%
aujourd'hui nous sommes trop dépendants
de Taïwan et les États-Unis ont
d'ailleurs pris la mesure puisque ils
ont ils sont en train de faire un effort
considérable pour une programmation de
production de semi-conducteur
pour en réaction justement contre cette
suprématie asiatique
sur les matières premières également
nous avons attiré l'attention sur un
certain nombre de matières premières
critiques comme l'aluminium le nickel le
titane et le palladium et sur le fait de
faire des stocks de sécurité qui doit
les faire c'est évidemment les
industriels mais l'État doit
certainement participer
pour assurer que ces stocks de matières
premières soient réelles
ce que on pense normalement je pense du
côté de du ministère des armées c'est
que l'État n'est pas simplement le
banquier je crois que sur cette question
et sur d'autres il est important de
signaler que les industriels doivent
prendre des risques je réponds un peu
aussi à votre question on doit prendre
des risques tout industriel prend des
risques quand il produit quelque chose
il n'y ait pas normal dès lors que les
industriels en matière de munition ne
prennent pas les mêmes risques
industriels et même risque commercial et
même risque financiers que d'industriels
normes normaux
sur les normes on va on parlera tout à
l'heure des normes d'énormeriches et
peut-être des des dérogations que l'on
que l'on souhaite voir acter mais
simplement de manière générale la France
et la championne des normes comme on le
sait les dents sont très très
compliquées la DGA applique parfois de
manière assez rigoureuse ces missions et
la mission notamment de qualification et
de certification parfois même elle va
au-delà de ce que demande les
industriels en sur la durée des de
d'utilisation de certaines conditions
donc c'est tantôt c'est restrictif
tantôt c'est un peu plus un peu plus
large tout ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
de manière générale ce qu'on
souhaiterait c'est qu'on se mette à au
niveau et au standard de l'OTAN puisque
de toute façon il est possible
d'utiliser des munitions qui viennent
des États-Unis dans certains dans
certains dans certaines situations je
pense à des missiles et par conséquent
si nos standards sont plus exigeants que
les standards de l'OTAN je pense qu'il
peut y avoir un assouplissement de ce
point de vue là puis alors sur enfin sur
les normes il y a aussi la question de
l'acier mais enfin je n'y reviens pas
parce que on l'a on l'a traité
voilà
juste un complément du coup sur le sur
les stocks de matières premières je
pense que les industriels sont prêts à
faire l'effort de faire un stock de
matières premières si encore une fois on
a cette garantie de commande sur la
durée ce qui n'est pas forcément le cas
aujourd'hui donc c'est pour ça qu'il ne
souhaite pas prendre le risque ce qui
est ce qui est compréhensible je pense
que ce problème de stockage de matière
première sera résolu le jour où on aura
des commandes sur plusieurs années du
moins une garantie il y avait une
question d'ailleurs dans ce sens là je
crois que c'était monsieur cuberta fond
monsieur Thiriau sur cette sur un
plancher en fait on a on a proposé un
plancher une commande plancher de de
munitions qui garantiraient donc une
production minimale sur le sur le long
terme ce qui permettrait donc d'avoir
une visibilité pour ces industriels et
donc qui pourrait prendre le risque
entre guillemets de faire des
investissements sur sur cette matière
première sachant que à mon sens ce n'est
pas incompatible avec un stock un stock
d'urgence de matière première étatique
ce qui permettrait un cas d'urgence
d'avoir cette garantie en plus des
stocks de des industriels voilà je vais
revenir sur le sur le petit calibre on a
eu plusieurs questions à ce sens donc
sur le sur le petit calibre je pense que
vraiment pertinent le projet le projet
du ministère de l'intérieur on partage
cette cette vision des choses
un projet qui semble-t-il assez avancé
qui serait donc un projet de société
type SAS public privé ce qui permettrait
d'avoir un avantage sur les sur les
prises de commandes directement par par
le ministère et la DGA
donc il y avait une question sur
l'acteur privé qui serait impliqué donc
je ne sais pas si on peut citer mais bon
effectivement
voilà il a été cité dans de nouvelles
sports effectivement impliqué sur le sur
ce dossier là on a aussi donc des
acteurs donc de qui produisent des
matières premières
françaises donc ils sont qui sont
impliqués sur sur qui serait impliqués
sur ce projet là je passe un coup pour
la poudre par exemple donc on a vraiment
aujourd'hui tous les écosystème et
toutes les
déjà coché toutes les cases aujourd'hui
pour que ce projet aboutisse il n'y
avait plus qu'une question de de volonté
politique je pense pour que ce projet
aboutisse assez court terme au final
parce qu'on nous parle on nous a parlé
de munitions des fin 2024 donc c'est un
projet quand même qui semble assez
avancé et après à démarrer assez
rapidement
voilà donc ce je pense que cette
relocalisation est indispensable on en a
parlé on n'était pas dans la même
logique il y a quelques années donc on a
parlé donc de cette filière avait fermé
pour des raisons économiques
je ne partage pas forcément ce choix
parce que encore une fois je pense que
la souveraineté doit être placée au
dessus des logiques économiques dans ce
dans ce domaine régalien mais
aujourd'hui donc les cartes sont
rebattues on en a parlé donc au vu de
l'inflation et du marché de la petite
munition il y a une vraie il y a une
vraie plus-value aujourd'hui à
relocaliser cette activité là à la fois
pour notre pour notre indépendance mais
aussi d'un point de vue économique on
nous a indiqué que sur les munitions sur
sur une munitions on ferait une économie
de 6 centimes par rapport au marché
international donc ce n'est pas neutre
et ce marché là serait viable uniquement
ne serait-ce qu'avec les les marchés
nationaux que sont donc les ministères
de l'Intérieur pour les forces de
l'ordre les douanes au niveau du
ministère des économies de l'économie au
niveau des agents pénitenciers et donc
potentiellement le ministère des armées
sachant que donc on commencerait sur sur
du petit calibre 9 mm qui permettrait
donc de
retrouver cette compétence
et ce
ces process là en vue éventuellement de
créer dans un second temps d'autres
d'autres chaînes par exemple sur sur du
556 qui serait encore plus pertinent
pour pour nous armées ou du 12-7 donc il
y a vraiment une plus-value à retrouver
cette industrie de petit calibre en
France à mon sens
si vous me permettez je voudrais quand
même donner mon point de vue sur ce
petit calibre naturellement je partage à
peu près ce qu'a dit mon collègue bien
évidemment mais il y a quand même
quelques tempéraments à avoir d'abord ce
n'est qu'un projet c'est qui n'est pas
abouti la foire en société en forme de
société n'est pas n'est pas du tout
abouti deuxièmement ça ne concerne que
le 9 mm c'est-à-dire les forces de
l'ordre la police la gendarmerie les
douanes les gardiens de prison les
sociétés de sécurité privée et le
continuum de police municipale mais
actuellement ce n'est pas envisagé pour
le 5 56 donc ça ne concerne pas
directement pour l'instant la défense
donc c'est un deuxième troisièmement ça
doit être évidemment rentable comme on
l'a dit il s'agit pas de le financer et
quatrièmement
certes si ça ce projet peut aboutir et
notamment en Bretagne comme on le
souhaite tant mieux mais il ne faut pas
laisser de côté d'autres pistes et
celles que j'ai indiquées c'est-à-dire
une coopération entre la France et la
Belgique pour aboutir aux mêmes
résultats avec l'incertitude là que l'on
touchera le 9 mm c'est-à-dire
le 5 56 pardonnez-moi c'est-à-dire des
armes qui concernent bien la défense
nationale française
juste le dernier complément sur sur
cette relocalisation donc on a des
chiffres entre 40 et 100 millions
d'euros pour pour relancer l'activité ce
qui me paraît quand même assez moindre
par rapport à notre LPM donc voilà je
pense que c'est encore une fois c'est
une question de choix politique c'est
pas un investissement déraisonnable et
encore une fois c'est une garantie de
notre souveraineté nationale
je on avait une question sur la garantie
sur les hausses de cadence de production
dans un contexte de haute intensité déjà
donc je pense que cette cette visibilité
à long terme permettra aux entreprises
de réinvestir sur éventuellement des
nouvelles des nouvelles chaînes de
production qui permettra de s'adapter
plus facilement à une hausse de la
cadence et ensuite il y a cette question
donc je pense je pense notamment à la
réserve opérationnelle et la réserve
industrielle qui qui je pense sont des
pistes intéressantes justement pour
avoir une certaine souplesse au delà
donc des salariés des entreprises
actuellement c'est réserves permettrait
justement de pouvoir faire appel à ces
court terme à des personnes déjà formées
donc que ce soit donc des jeunes
retraités du secteur ou des personnes
des techniciens qui sont qui sont encore
en activité mais qui seraient détachés
pour renforcer notre industrie de
défense en cas de besoin voilà je pense
que c'est indispensable et je pense que
c'est aussi corrélé au fait de retrouver
un stock de munitions si on a un stock
de munitions conséquence ça nous
permettra de pouvoir pour anticiper
sur sur des sur des sur une durée un peu
plus raisonnable la montée en puissance
de nos industriels voilà le fait de ne
pas avoir aujourd'hui de stock de
munitions nécessaires risque
effectivement de mettre en difficulté
notre nos industriels si on a un STO de
munitions
relativement conséquent on aura une
visibilité et une possibilité de nous
adapter sur le sur un peu plus sur un
sur un terme un peu plus raisonnable
pour Monsieur Thiriot qui nous a quitté
il parlait évidemment de risques
industriels j'y ai répondu de vision à
long terme et également il parlait de
comment faire des des accords avec les
industriels sous quelle forme est-ce
qu'on a réfléchi un petit peu à cela
alors il a parlé de commande ferme de
l'être d'intention oui c'est le
mécanisme des lettres d'intention avec
une commande de la DGA en partenariat
évidemment avec le ministère des armées
et en coopération avec les industriels
il y a également une autre formule c'est
les contrats plancher plus ruelles qui
sont utilisés par nos amis britanniques
et allemands qui garantit aux
industriels un flux minimal de
production ça peut être également une
autre piste
je rappelle que en matière de
risque de conflit de haute intensité il
y a une procédure un peu accélérée qui
s'appelle l'urgence opération si
l'urgence est avérée qui peut être
utilisé s'il ne s'agit pas de mettre de
côté le CODES publics mais d'accélérer
la procédure de manière générale donc il
faut assurer une régularité des
commandes pour éviter des ruptures de
production des pertes de compétences et
des pertes de confiance avec les
industriels
j'étais pardon sur la question de Madame
Martinez sur la préparation
opérationnelle effectivement c'est un
enjeu et ça ça coalle sur cette logique
de stock ça serait un atout pour nous
alors ça serait d'en parler la semaine
dernière et encore ce matin la
préparation opérationnelle munition
réelle et nécessaire elle ne remplacera
jamais totalement la simulation et puis
l'avantage de cette de cette préparation
opérationnelle à balle réelle et plus
régulièrement permet également de faire
rouler ce stock ce stock de munition on
va aujourd'hui avec sur des munitions
complexes
nos opérateurs nos militaires n'ont pas
forcément tiré ne serait-ce qu'une seule
munition de de munitions complexe donc
ça pose effectivement des problèmes et
le fait de tirer donc des munitions qui
arrivent peut-être à midi ou en fin de
vie permet justement ce roulement qui
est nécessaire et on doit effectivement
je pense encourager ces entraînements à
munition réel sachant qu'il n'est pas
forcément évident de faire des économies
attirer avec des munitions
d'entraînement on en a parlé donc ça les
munitions d'entraînement on le
désavantage de voir nécessite un nouveau
process une nouvelle chaîne une nouvelle
chaîne par rapport à la fabrication de
chaîne de chaîne de munitions réelles et
donc le les économies à faire des
munitions d'entraînement ne sont pas
forcément évidents voire même des
parfois plus coûteuses que des munitions
réelles donc pour nous on a je pense que
il est vraiment avantageux à tout point
de vue de faire tirer d'entraîner aux
militaires avec des balles réelles
alors pour Josie Puerto donc il y avait
je crois deux questions me semble-t-il
d'abord une question de ressources
humaines et une question d'énormes
riches c'est bien ça sur les ressources
humaines on touche là l'économie de
guerre comment monter en puissance les
industriels nous ont dit qu'ils étaient
capables d'augmenter les les cadences de
production en particulier avec le 3 8 le
travail le week-end
peut-être en situation de guerre
nécessité faisant loi il peut y avoir
des adaptations au code du travail mais
enfin ceci n'est pas abordé encore mais
il est certain que c'est une possibilité
la deuxième possibilité qu'on a indiqué
c'est que dans des industries dual où il
y a une activité civile et une activité
militaire il serait possible autant que
de besoin de basculer effectivement les
personnels civils vers de la production
militaire si évidemment ils en ont les
compétences les formations peuvent être
faites et vérifiées troisièmement il y a
la réserve industrielle effectivement un
gros industriel nous a évoqué cette
possibilité de réserve industrielle qui
permettrait en effet à des jeunes
retraités déjà ne retraités jeune ou un
jeune d'ailleurs ou des personnes qui
ont quitté l'entreprise de revenir sur
statut civil bien sûr de salariés pour
renforcer les équipes et enfin moi je
proposais la réserve opérationnelle
puisque le chef de l'État a bien dit que
la réserve opérationnelle s'était pas
uniquement de manière sur le front mais
que ça pouvait être consacré à d'autres
tâches comme la cyberph aller élargir
cette notion de réserve opérationnelle
et nous pensons que cette réserve
opérationnelle pourrait permettre à
plusieurs centaines de personnes sous
statut militaire donc réserve
opérationnel d'abonder les effectifs des
industries deuxième question c'est rich
je vais passer très rapidement ce sont
des activités vous avez raison de le
rappeler qu'ils sont des activités
dangereuses par définition dans des
installations classées pour la
protection de l'environnement des ICPE
alors les normeriches ont entrés en
vigueur au premier juin 2007
elles imposent des contraintes
extrêmement sévères les quantités
doivent être précisées soumises à
autorisation parfois même dans des
proportions limitées parfois même des
utilisations prohibées et c'est donc
assez compliqué de discuter notamment
avec
l'Union européenne parce qu'il faut
chaque fois
se justifier ça entraîne un allongement
considérable considérable des délais et
surtout cela a un coût considérable
n'est pas le temps de citer le le J4
mais nous avons des chiffres qui
montrent que on perd 12 à 18 mois et que
ça concerne des millions d'euros qui
doivent être qui doivent être mis donc
allongement des délais d'obtention
autorisation de la commission européen
difficile à obtenir des coûts qui sont
évalués à 300 millions d'euros pour un
industriel c'est considérable et j'ai
cité le plomb et le sel de plomb tout à
l'heure dans dans l'exposé ce qui est
compliqué alors notre proposition que la
proposition numéro 7 pour aller vite
c'est de dire que on souhaiterait non
pas supprimer évidemment ces normes qui
sont importantes sur le plan de
l'environnement tout le monde est
d'accord et sur le plan de
l'acceptabilité sociale qui est aussi
quelque chose de très important mais on
pense qu'on pourrait
modifier un petit peu donner plus
d'exemption obtenir des exemptions de la
part de ministère de la transition
écologique c'est en tout cas la
proposition qui est faite
je vais essayer d'aller rapidement donc
sur les dernières questions si je peux
donc au niveau de des propos donc
récemment tenu donc sur le fait que le
l'Europe est à court de munition bon
notre rapport s'est arrêté au cadre au
cadre national donc je n'irai pas
m'engager sur le sur le climat open mais
pour ce qu'il en est de notre propre
stock effectivement nous ne sommes pas
en mesure aujourd'hui de tenir un
conflit de haute intensité et donc je
pense qu'il y a eu une prise une prise
de conscience
récente qui vise à combler donc ce
déficit maintenant il n'y a plus qu'à
faire sur
l'interopérabilité
au niveau européen donc effectivement
c'est un enjeu c'est un enjeu clé
d'autant plus que le Président de la
République veut qu'on soit une nation
cadre et qu'effectivement si on veut si
on veut mener si on veut mener des
opérations et être à la tête de fil de
ses opérations effectivement nous devons
nous devons avoir un stock conséquent et
pouvoir pouvoir se mutualiser entre
allier donc effectivement je rebondis
d'ailleurs sur ce sujet là sur le sur le
sujet du stock mais s'il y a aussi un
enjeu de crédibilité au-delà de l'aspect
opérationnel au niveau de la de notre
diplomatie et de notre guide crédibilité
à l'international si nous ne sommes pas
en capacité
de
d'être indépendant sur sur nos stocks de
munitions nous perdons effectivement de
crédibilité sur la scène internationale
et donc il est nécessité de reconstituer
un stock important
sur le l'avantage des relocalisations
donc effectivement au-delà de l'aspect
opérationnel
relocaliser des activités de production
de munitions notamment donc dans le dans
ce cas précis la petite mission
permettra effectivement de recréer de
l'emploi dans le pays il y a une notion
économique non négligeable notamment
dans des territoires
ou la désindustrialisation a fait son
oeuvre notre industrie de défense est
répartie sur l'ensemble du territoire il
n'est pas
en général n'est pas un métropole
justement donc on a tout intérêt je
pensais à développer cette industrie de
défense notamment que les acteurs
principaux font travailler énormément de
sous-traitants je pense à un BDA qui a
16 sous-traitants et c'est souvent des
TPE PME donc ça va renforcer tout notre
tissu économique qui que bénéficiera de
fait aussi le marché civil parce que nos
entreprises de défense ont souvent dual
et d'autant plus je pense leur
sous-traitants donc on a tout intérêt à
relocaliser certaines activités
juste une dernière chose sur le
panachage donc il a été question donc de
de
massifier donc nos stocks et nos
munitions voilà on a souligné dans notre
rapport le fait qu'il fallait donc
réinvestir sur des munitions de masse de
façon à pouvoir saturer
nos opposants dans un conflit de haute
intensité
c'est une nécessité mais ça ne
remplacera pas des munitions complexes
qui permettent
qui ne sont pas de qui n'ont pas la même
utilité sur le champ de bataille et qui
permettent de neutraliser des cibles
plus
on va dire plus avec une plus forte
valeur ajoutée plus sensible et qui sont
donc ces munitions sont plus précises
donc voilà encore une fois c'est je
pense que c'est une caisse à outils
on peut avoir une belle personne mais il
faut également avoir un marteau qui
fonctionne bien c'est c'est il faut
avoir toute cette palette d'outils et
donc pour rappel ces petits ces
munitions rustiques pourraient
neutraliser 90% des cibles des cibles en
opération et 10% et 10% restantes sont
de la faire des missions complexes
je vois peut-être que la liberté soit
intervenir mais 10 secondes maximum en
allumant le micro
la coopération avec
l'entreprise que je citerai pas de
Bretagne n'est pas incompatible avec la
Belgique
mais
merci en tout cas
merci en tout cas nos collègues
rancouler et brut pour leur excellent
travail et bien entendu on sera tous
attentif à la publication du rapport que
je vais d'ailleurs vous demander
d'autoriser la publication je vois pas
d'opposition pas d'abstention merci et
bon appétit à tous tout simplement